we have a voicemail number you can call
that number any time of day it runs 24
7. and you can really say anything you
want now a few things I will mention the
maximum voicemail length is three
minutes we never play three minute
voicemails on the show so if you find
that you're getting cut off by the beep
because you've used the full amount of
time
you're probably talking at least three
times longer than you should if you
swear it probably won't be used because
then we have to bleep it Etc
and if you're going to criticize me
please criticize me for things that I
have actually done or said rather than
things that I haven't okay here is
someone who tuned in to one of our
streams I guess of a trump speech and
didn't like how I was treating the
president
the sorry the former they call them the
president uh the for the failed former
president of course I was watching on
your show the Trump speech
irregardless of any political
affiliation
you were very immature and very rude
okay I guess that's it there's nothing
else yeah you know there I often will
get emails we'll cover some Trump event
and folks will search around YouTube for
a live stream and sometimes they'll come
across my live stream during which I
comment I give my opinion and my opinion
of trump is quite low uh I don't think
he deserves too much praise and
um as a result people will email me and
say how dare you disrespect the office
of the presidency and we shouldn't talk
about any president you can't be
negative you've got to be what are you
talking about what are you talking about
this is this this is the United States
of America we if if you want to talk
about decorum and tone your real concern
should be the way in which Trump's lack
of decorum
uh completely debased the office of the
presidency for four years folks are
worried I'm mean to Trump yet they
weren't worried about Trump mimicking a
disabled reporter and the thousands of
things that he did give me a break guys
we have a fantastic bonus show for you
today it's really a good one oh the
bonus show where you want to make money
everybody else that makes money to fund
themselves is bad today's bonus show
we're actually not going to make money
on but we are going to discuss
um it turns out that that billionaire
Harlan Crowe Clarence Thomas's friend
paid School tuition for some kid that
wasn't isn't uh Clarence Thomas's son
but that Clarence Thomas sort of was
like bothering it's a it's yet another
really weird story involving Clarence
Thomas number two Republicans are
Furious that Joe Biden is sending troops
to the Border even though it's what they
wanted now they're mad that it's
happening okay and we will discuss the
new Utah law that has now gone into
effect
requiring all sorts of verification to
browse pornography websites it's wacky
what is going on socially in Utah it's
one of the most backward States socially
in the country and we're going to talk
about that and much much more all of
those stories on today's bonus show
which you can access by signing up at
joinpakman.com full price is a great
deal
but you can use the coupon code 24
starts now 2-4 starts now all one word
no spaces uppercase lowercase doesn't
matter 24 starts now will save you about
50 percent off of the cost of a
membership we'll see you then and then
back tomorrow on the Friday show